I've always been an adrenaline junkie.
I love driving fast in my car.
I love zipping through the woods on my snowboard, my skis, and I really love backflipping my
BMX bike.
What I haven't really experienced was flight.
It was something that I'd always been interested in, but hadn't had a lot of experience with,
and specifically helicopter flight.
I always thought that was the most awesome craft to pilot, being quick and light and
nimble, and when I saw an ad in the Westward paper announcing an introductory offer for
30 minutes of sightseeing and 30 minutes of instructional time, I felt like it was speaking
directly to me.
So I called them up immediately and set my appointment, and for the next few days I
was extremely excited for that day.
So when the day came, I got to the office early.
I'm never early, for anything, but I was early on this day, and I'm walking into the office
and I look over and I see a motorcycle in the shadows, this really cool looking motorcycle,
and I remember thinking, these are my people.
So I go in, I sign my name, I go out with the pilot, we look at the helicopter, we get
inside, butterflies are going, I am so pumped, it's time, I'm going to fly this thing.
I got my own set of controls, he has his own set of controls, we get our little lap belts
on, get our headsets on, and then the pilot points over at this fire extinguisher and
he says, I need you to promise me something, and I'm going to promise you something too.
If you are on fire, I promise I will put you out.
So I say back to him, if you are on fire, I promise I will put you out.
He gives me a high five, we start it up, the main rotor blade starts spinning and we just
lift off the ground, he just takes us right up and it's got a glass floor, I'm looking
at it and it's like jumping my bike but never coming down, we just continue to go up and
up and I am so stoked, we're flying around and you wouldn't believe, just out past the
dirt roads, it is like an African savanna, a safari, you just see things that you would
never see or realize are just out there past the city.
We get up and I see this herd of deer and it's so beautiful, they're like running because
they hear the helicopter and they're in a big pack and they're looking over their shoulders
and we're flying above them and I'm just like how cool is this, nobody would ever get to
see this and so then he zips into this little, this empty river bed and then just starts
gunning it through this river bed like 15, 20 feet above the ground and I'm loving it,
there's trees on either side of us and we're just zipping, winding through it and I'm just
like this is so cool, I say to him, dude you need to get an awesome stereo system in this
thing man, you can just rock out and he looks over at me like yeah, yeah, this is good right
and I'm just envisioning this, I'm having this whole fantasy in my head, I'm like I'm
going to get one of these someday, I'm going to have my own helicopter, I'm going to tint
the windows, I'm going to paint it like a dragonfly, I'm going to put a sweet stereo
system in this thing, people are going to be looking up in the air like hey there's
Brian, look at him, so I'm just in this fantasy world, just so stoked, we're just hauling
ass around, I love it and then he comes up out of there and he says alright, play time's
over, business time, time for you to learn a little bit, anybody that's going to be a
real pilot needs to know this, it's an emergency drill, it's an auto rotation, basically I'm
going to cut the power, it's like putting your car into neutral going downhill, main
rotor blade's going to keep spinning but there's going to be a big drop in altitude
at the beginning, you like Elitch's rides and you know, roller coasters, that kind of
stuff, you got a soft stomach or are you pretty tough, I'm like I'm good with that, I'm cool,
he's okay, okay cool, because if you have a problem just let me know, I'll land and
you can hurl, okay cool, bases are covered, let's do this, so sure enough, he kills the
power, woo, we get that like 30 foot drop just instantly in altitude, I feel the upward
draft of the air and we just kind of come into like this soft, slow drift and I'm getting
to feel what he's saying you can do if you have an emergency landing situation and then
I start looking at him, he's fidgeting with stuff, he's turning things, he's got a stressed
look on his face, I'm just like, everything alright, he looks at me with wild eyes, it's
like this is the real thing man, I can't believe it, I look out, I look down, it's
like a model railroad set, these tiny little trees and my first thought is we're going
to die, we are going to die, I signed up for this, I paid money to die, like you've got
to be kidding me, and I'm just watching and we're slowly starting to fall towards the
earth and I cannot believe this is happening, I'm just like this is a bad joke right, like
when's the camera's going to come out and he's going to smile and say, just kidding,
but he doesn't, he's just doing like S turns and figure eights and I'm just thinking, I
never expected that this would be my last day and I start having these crazy thoughts
like I put in some pictures to get developed, who's going to ever see those, who's going
to get my car, like it's parked down there and I'm just like, I can't believe that this
is the day, we're going to die, there's just no other way around it, you don't walk away
crash and so he starts looking like he may be able to land this thing, we're coming down
towards the ground and now my mind starts to shift from we're going to die to we're
going to get really worked, we're going to hit the ground and it's going to suck, I'm
going to be laying there with a broken back, it's just like I wear more pads when I'm riding
my bike, I've got a helmet and knee pads and I've got a little lap belt and this little
headset and we're in like a glass box, I'm just like, we're definitely going to get worked,
so admit it to yourself, the next hour is going to really suck, you know, and so here
we go, we're coming in for a landing, we're coming in about a 10, 12 degree angle, he's
doing good, he's got us going about 50 miles an hour straight towards the ground and he
just yells to me, he's like, we're going to hit and I just did the only thing I thought
seemed right, I just shut my eyes, I took a deep breath, I put my arms out in front
of my face and sure enough, we hit the ground and we just four by four across the prairie,
just like, you know, bouncing across the gopher holes and then the left skid digs into the
ground and it makes us stop instantly and we just jerk forward and then the main rotor
blade is just going super fast, it hits the ground and it just cartwheels the whole helicopter
and it smashes and breaks it right off behind our heads and we come to a stop looking at
the sky and there's just smoke and I can smell jet fuel and the flight manuals are all scattered
around inside the cockpit and I just shoulder the door and jump out and my feet touch the
ground and I just can't believe it, I'm just like, yes! And I look up and I'm just like,
oh my god, we were just up that high and now we're here and I have just like a tiny cut
on my pinky and I'm just astounded that this has just happened and then I look at the pilot
and he comes around the corner from his side and he's just like, I am so sorry, dude, I
am so sorry and I'm just like, thank you, you did it, you landed it and he's like, I'm so sorry,
Brian and I'm like, thank you and it goes on and on like this and I'm just, I'm beside myself,
I cannot believe it, I'm like, I'm fine and then he just, he turns into a stress case,
his hands are, his head's in his hands, he's just like, oh my god, I am so dead,
he's gonna have to make a full investigation, there's a $9,000 deductible, we just rebuilt
the thing, we gotta go find help, let's go, so off we go, we just go walking across the
prairie and I'm just like, a pie in the sky, just like, oh wow, this is crazy, wait till I tell my
friends about this one and he's stressed the whole walk and then we see a truck come rumbling down
the dirt road, we're like, hey, we wave down this truck, we hop over the fence, we flag these guys
down, they've got a CB in their truck, they call the paramedics, the cops, literally within minutes,
it's like every single emergency vehicle within a tri-state region is coming over the hill,
ambulances, fire trucks, cops, four-wheelers, everybody wants to see what's going on, a
helicopter crash and people lived, what? So it's crazy, you know, the paramedics insist that I'm
in shock and I'm injured, I had to have gotten hurt, I'm just not feeling it yet, even though
I've walked miles to get here, I'm like, I'm fine, I crash on a regular basis on my bike,
I'm good, I know when I'm hurt, but they insist on taking me to the hospital and checking me out
and giving me an IV of saline and so I'm laying there and I get interviewed by the news and my
phone is blowing up and it's just an insane day and I can't believe it, I'm like, it's a dream,
I just go home and I'm just like, what? And I'm laying in bed that night and I just, I'm laying
on my back, my head's on my pillow and I shut my eyes and I still feel like I'm falling, I still
feel like I'm slowly drifting to the earth and I'm like, you know, I think I'm gonna still live
boldly, I'm gonna still go fast in my car, I'm gonna still jump my bike and do crazy stuff,
but I don't think I need to learn how to fly a helicopter. Thank you.